why don't we go next to um
let's just try somewhere else let's go
to alfie in london now is that london uk
yeah yeah london uk well welcome you're
on the air
hey thanks for picking me um i just
thought would it be okay if i just use
you
as a way to settle a sort of long time
dispute
i can try sure i can try uh so would you
say
a flamingo is a pink or would you
say peach is probably a better way to
describe it
you know i think that flamingos i would
describe them as
salmon colored oh no
yeah i don't know oh no that's just made
it worse okay
i mean i think it's more uh i you know i
think it actually depends on
it depends now i know that there's
people who will say the flamingo is
white
but it takes on the color of of what it
eats
we're dealing it what color does it end
up right i think that's really the
question that you're asking
um i think it's regionally different to
be perfectly honest i think in some
cases it's more pink in some cases more
peach
okay yeah okay oh that doesn't help
david i'm sorry
um all right you'll vote in third party
right now by choosing salmon i hope you
know that
i'm sorry i'm doing what so oh by
choosing salmon i'm third party yes
listen how are things in london you guys
are doing so well with cases and deaths
being so low
um yeah i think it may be the calm
before the storm
oh everyone's talking about the indian
variant at the moment
the indian variant is well handled by
the vaccines from everything i've read
yeah yeah but it's just sort of the talk
of the town at the moment i see um
but yeah as of monday we're able to eat
indoors
groups of up to six people yep um yeah
it's looking good
what is your you know one of the things
i love about the uk in general is all of
the different pubs with different names
that are often very similar but just
slightly different like the you know
the lamb's head and the you know all
these different things
what is the name of your favorite pub
um oh this thing
do you mean do you mean my favorite name
of a pub or the name of my favorite
pub i will accept either but ideally one
that you like going to
um there is a really nice place in
london called the uh
the green pea love it yeah
and it's really nice um yeah i'm not
sure how they're doing at the moment
because their owner
they also own and operate by this one
guy who passed away
uh about a year back i'm sorry to hear
that
no it's yeah but it was a really nice
place local to us and so we went to
there all the time
and they do uh they do sunday roast and
everything yeah
yeah yeah you gotta love that sunday
roast you know
yeah i'm not the biggest fan me neither
there's a bit of um
sacrilegious yeah no i don't like it
well you just said you love it all right
my friend no i'm just kidding around i i
do actually like it last time i was
there i went to a great sunday roast uh
they had a vegan option a vegetarian
option
a meat-eaters option they had a pasta as
you say they had everything
honest all right thank you for the call
i really appreciate it
yep thanks for doing take michael thank
you all right perfect perfect call